bonjour à tous nous allons débuter ce
point presse par par une analyse de la
conférence du président françois
hollande
un président qui a été fidèle à
elle-même à lui même on pourrait
synthétiser sa conférence de presse par
il est urgent de ne pas agir ça a été
l'occasion d'une logorrhée
culpabilisante beignets de bons
sentiments
il a passé plus de 20 minutes sur la
question des migrants de manière assez
floue d'ailleurs il est revenu sur sa
position de de la fin juin où il était
contre les quotas aujourd'hui il faut il
faut recevoir at il annoncé 24 mille
migrants puis puis très rapidement il
est passé sur sur les sujets qui
concernent les français c'est à dire le
chômage la crise des agriculteurs
là les questions de justice d'éducation
et de santé il n'y a consacré que que
quelques quelques minutes à croire que
ceux qui concernent au quotidien les
français ne l'intéresse pas
véritablement nous sommes passés d'un
président de la passivité à un président
de l'inaction qui semble être totalement
dépassée qui se laisse porter par par
les événements et l'actualité
internationale
nous avons également pu remarquer cette
ce nouveau mois président qui est faire
des choix
il a répété à plusieurs reprises faire
des choix pour finalement ne jamais
tranché et ne venant faire à aucun
moment de sa de sa conférence de presse
donc cela nous a semblé tout de même
assez inquiétant
voilà un moment assez grave où la
situation de la france est dramatique où
l'actualité internationale est
dramatique
le président ne se présente pas devant
les français ne s'exprime pas de vent et
français mais tient peut-être l'unique
promesses de son quinquennat celle de
faire une conférence de presse tous les
six mois
voilà donc finalement il est à la
hauteur de la déception qu'il suscite
depuis depuis trois ans l'inaction est
encore là et et que ce soit que ce soit
sur la question des impôts de la crise
migratoire du code du travail ou de la
crise syrienne il est il est encore dans
le flou et comme disait martine aubry
quand c'est flou c'est qu'il ya un loup
et et les français voient chaque jour
chaque semaine qui passe que les loups
sont nombreux et françois hollande fait
bonjour à tous françois hollande a
beaucoup parlé mais il n'a pas dit grand
chose aujourd'hui et nous sommes restés
sur notre faim
on espérait qu'on nous donne un cap pour
la fin du quinquennat
il n'y a pas de cap y a pas de cap pour
cette dernière ligne droite du
quinquennat de françois hollande on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya pas de vision il n'y
a pas de choix
il nous a répété comme l'a dit il ya
quelques instants lydia il faut faire
des choix il faut faire des choix pour
la france il faut faire des choix pour
l'europe il faut faire des choix pour le
monde
le problème c'est que ils n'ont ils
n'ont fait aucun il n'en donne aucun de
ces choix
il m'a fait penser un peu à cette phrase
de coluche je vais bientôt faire un
choix je vais pas tarder à faire un
choix je vais faire un choix
mais voilà le choix n'arrive pas et puis
il ya un manque plus totale de
leadership
c'est à dire qu'on attend d'un président
de la république qu'ils soient devant il
est un effet d'entraînement et il n'a
pas d'effet d'entraînement ni pour la
france ni à l'international
donc c'est vraiment la crise du
leadership
dans notre pays et puis on attendait des
mots des propositions pour résoudre la
crise du chômage
françois hollande a érigé le chômage en
symbole en en faisant la condition
sinequanone d'un versement de la courbe
pour sa candidature en 2017
or on s'aperçoit que on a un président
de la république est déjà en campagne
électorale pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 mais qui a
complètement et éluder la problématique
du chômage
à l'occasion de cette conférence de
presse
donc nous avons un président à la peine
un président qui a raté sa rentrée qui
n'a fait que répéter des choses qu il
avait annoncé je pense à la baisse des
impôts
on a cru comprendre simplement que ces
deux milliards de réduction d'impôt qui
l'avait déjà annoncé aller se faire
vraisemblablement sur l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est la seule petite information
que nous ayons eue sur le financement
on a appris simplement que cela il
allait financer ces deux milliards par
des économies mais on ne sait toujours
pas dans quel domaine auront lieu ces
économies et puis donc il nous a parlé
mai sur des réfugiés mais finalement on
a un revirement de situation il zigzague
sur les positions il y a encore six
semaines
il n'était pas question de quotas
aujourd'hui il nous a fait tout un
discours en donnant la définition du
quota mais sans prononcer le mot quota
donc je pense qu'à un moment il faut
appeler un chat un chat et reconnaître
on a changé d'avis et reconnaître avec
les mots pour le dire que du quota qu'on
refusait il ya six semaines et bien
maintenant on est d'accord et on est
d'accord pour en faire une obligation
donc face à cette indécision face à ces
revirements et bien on a
nous chez les républicains président qui
a clairement affirmé les choses
notamment à l'occasion de l'université
d'été régional de la baule où nicolas
sarkozy a bien affirmé
les positions des républicains c'est à
dire que il faut des centres de
rétention à vocation humanitaire aux
frontières de l'europe aux frontières de
schengen pour vérifier que ceux qui
répondent aux critères du droit d'asile
et bien peuvent rentrer et que les
autres qui sont des migrants économiques
et bien malheureusement nous ne pourrons
pas les accueillir
et donc il a réaffirmé aussi la
nécessité de définir des critères
communs pour les membres de l'union dans
le cadre du droit d'asile et ça c'est
très important il faut que les critères
soient identiques quelle que soit quels
que soient les pays
françois hollande lors de la conférence
de presse après une question d'un
journaliste qui évoquait les les actes
de délinquance qui ont eu sur qui a qui
ont lieu sur l'autoroute a1 par par des
gens du voyage a cru bon d'esquiver en
évoquant les agriculteurs agriculteurs
ont manifesté de manière légale ils ont
déposé une demande à la préfecture qui a
été accepté et ont manifesté de manière
légitime puisque ce sont des personnes
qui aujourd'hui ne parviennent plus à
vivre de leur travail et nous trouvons
que que la comparaison entre ces actes
de délinquance qui ont bloqué pendant
plusieurs heures des personnes qui
revenaient de vacances sur l'autoroute
a1 était absolument mal venu et que
quelque part ça démontre à quel point
françois hollande ne comprend plus du
tout la france car il est grave qu'un
président de la république compare les
dégradations qui ont lieu sur
l'autoroute a2 la part des gens du
voyage à celle aux manifestations
d'agriculteurs qui n'ont absolument
rien dégrader d'ailleurs alors nous
avons voilée il ya eu une élection
partielle qui a eu lieu hier dans
l'aveyron avec des résultats pour le
candidat à l'est républicain
arnaud viala qui est qui a fait une très
belle performance plus de 46% c'est une
progression de plus de huit points dans
une circonscription qui était à gauche
qui avait voté en 2012 à plus de 53 %
pour françois hollande
donc ce que 17 cette élection c'est que
le bloc de gauche s'effondre une fois de
plus il est à peu près aux alentours de
22 % donc arnaud viala remplace alain
marc qui qui part au sénat et c'est une
très bonne nouvelle qui confirme que
notre stratégie est la bonne
le mot sur l'agenda donc mercredi 9
septembre à 17 heures aura lieu la
commission exécutive dans cette maison
et ce même mercredi 9 septembre il y
aura de 8 heures à 20 heures le vote
pour l'élection des jeunes républicains
il en sera dit quelques mots par la
suite le samedi 12 septembre et le
dimanche 13 septembre où auront lieu le
premier campus national des jeunes
républicains ou touquet et pour cela je
vais laisser la parole à daniel
fasquelle député maire du touquet et
trésorier des républiques écouter
bonjour à tous ici c'était sagement
assis en écoutant nos porte parole on
approuve ya évidemment tout ce qu'ils
viennent de de vous dire et avec antoine
si dany qui est le responsable des
jeunes du nord du nord pas de calais qui
va prendre des responsabilités
nationales ont souhaité vous dire
quelques go du campus du touquet alors
c'est un moment pour nous très important
parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de campus
national des jeunes depuis 2011
il ya eu des campus régionaux on en a
organisé certains au touquet-paris-plage
il a permis d'ailleurs d'acquérir un
certain savoir faire mais depuis 2011
depuis marseille avait pas eu de réunion
ii campus national des jeunes et donc ça
va être pour nous un moment très
important
de la même façon il n'ya pas eu
d'élection équipes nationales des jeunes
depuis 2010 donc on va avec élection qui
va se dérouler dans quelques jours
avoir une nouvelle équipe nationale des
jeunes et cette nouvelle équipe
nationale déjà nous aller les découvrir
à l'occasion de ce campus est quelque
part c'est nicolas sarkozy s'est fait
élire à la tête de l'ump devenu les
républicains pour remettre la machine en
route
pour remettre le parti sur les rails
c'est une nouvelle étape importante qui
va être franchie avec ce campus est avec
cette nouvelle équipe nationale avant la
dernière étape qui consistera dans des
élections qui auront lieu au mois de
janvier dans les différentes fédérations
enfin c'est la preuve que le mouvement
va bien qu'il est à nouveau en bonne
forme et que nous allons à nouveau de
l'avant en faisant une vraie place aux
jeunes et s'agissant de ce campus que je
veux dire aussi c'est que on a fait
totalement confiance aux jeunes puisque
ce sont les jeunes antoine va en parler
qui ont préparé ce campus de a à z
alors on n'a pas fait appel à des
sociétés intermédiaires qui aurait pu
nous aider éventuellement à tout a été
fait en direct
la réservation des salles l'organisation
des repas la réservation de ceux qui
vont par exemple sonorisé l'événement
tout a été fait en direct avec un petit
coup de main quand même de l'équipe
nationale qui avait préparé le congrès
dans la même condition le congrès de
mois de mai dernier
donc tout cela se fait dans le cadre
d'un budget aussi qui est un budget
extrêmement maîtrisé sachant que les
jeunes mettre la main à la poche puisque
75% du budget sera financé par les
jeunes eux-mêmes puisque ce sont eux qui
financent à la fois le repas et leur
logement on leur donne juste un petit
coup de main des fédérations qui le
peuvent pour le déplacement
et quand le national c'est trésorier qui
parle d'un aussi un petit coup de main
pour faire en sorte que le campus qui
est un campus régional campus touquet
soit un campus national pour pouvoir
vous accueillir dans les meilleures
conditions c'est un petit surcoût que le
national va naturellement prendre en
compte
c'est aussi un campus mais ça je vais
laisser en toi d'en parler moderne et
interactif de par les moyens qui ont été
déployés pour
faire connaître le campus aux jeunes et
les jeunes qui seront sur place
il ya des jeunes qui pourront pas se
déplacer pour plein de raisons et ses
jeunes pourront pendant le campus
participer y compris aux ateliers de par
les moyens qui vont être mis en oeuvre
donc ce sera aussi le premier campus
parfaitement moderne et interactif
j'ajouterai que ce campus
il a lieu dans une région qui est un
jour particulière puisque c'est la
région nord pas de calais picardie une
région dans laquelle pour les élections
régionales nous serons face à marine le
pen est donc xavier bertrand sera
évidemment présent à l'occasion ce
campus au côté du président nicolas
sarkozy et que ce sera aussi pour nous
l'occasion de mobiliser les jeunes de la
grande région nord pas de calais
picardie pour ce combat est un combat
pour nous extrêmement important on ne
veut pas que marie le pen dirige cette
région veut que ce soit xavier bertrand
et on va se mobiliser en conséquence et
sachez que pour ce qui est des jeunes
non seulement va l'immobiliser
évidemment pour animer la campagne mais
avec xavier bertrand nous avons bien
l'intention d'en faire une vraie place
sur les listes dans un département dans
le pas de calais où moi j'ai souhaité
depuis je suis président de la
fédération il ya trois ans donner une
vraie place aux jeunes à chaque élection
aux élections municipales
on a donné l'investiture à des jeunes
qui avait 22 23 25 en 26 ans certains
aujourd'hui son maire d'autres son
adjoint premier adjoint ont pris des
responsabilités importantes ça a été
vrai aussi en des départementales et
sébastien qui appartient la région quoi
au pic du chef on fera en sorte aussi
évidemment que dans que dans le nord et
dans tous les départements les jeunes
soient en bonne place sur nos listes
pour les régionales puis je terminerai
en disant qu'il y aura un beau plateau
puisque ce sont les jeunes évidemment
qui se retrouvent et qu'ils se donnent
rendez vous entre eux donc c'est d'abord
et avant tout un rendez-vous déjà les
jeunes donnent rendez vous aux jeunes et
vont débattre entre eux maintenant
évidemment les jeunes ont invité leurs
aînés et sont heureux de les accueillir
à cette occasion donc il y aura le
président nicolas sarkozy qui
interviendra lors d'une réunion publique
un temps fort qui aura lieu le samedi
à 17h30 xavier bertrand interviendra
aussi à ce moment là on aura la chance
aussi d'accueillir nathalie kosciusko
morizet luc chatel laurent wauquiez
christian estrosi eric woerth michèle
alliot-marie françois baroin aussi qui
viendra ça nous fait très plaisir c'est
la première fois qu'il viendra au campus
du touquet edouard courtial et puis
beaucoup d'autres qui sont bien
évidemment invités à nous à nous
rejoindre
je crois d'ailleurs que dans la liste il
va y avoir des élections dans quelques
jours est l'occasion de ces élections il
y à déjà vraiment de toute sensibilité
qui supporteront tous les candidats de
la primaire donc tous les candidats à la
primaire sont bien évidemment comme tous
les jeunes invités à ce campus et je
crois que ça fait vraiment plaisir aux
jeunes que certains même si voilà il
avait prévu d'autres choses bouscule ou
s'ils le peuvent bousculer leur alors
leur âge d'or agenda et leur emploi du
temps pour venir saluer les jeunes c'est
important de montrer que l'ensemble du
bureau politique que tous les
responsables nationaux sont aux côtés
des jeunes républicains dont on veut
faire vraiment voilà une force de frappe
pour les échéances futures
voilà je laisse la parole antoine donc
pour le campus comme l'a si bien dit
daniel sera encore plus interactif et
moderne déjà la façon de communiquer on
a créé une application campus
républicain qui a été téléchargé plus de
trois mille fois il me semble donc sa
véritable succès ont montré par des
moyens modernes pas besoin de courriers
papier tout était fait par le net
ensuite ce sera également un campus
moderne dans le sens où même les jeunes
mais si bien dit daniel pascal qui ne
seront pas présents pourront interagir
avec la salle donc via twitter via le
web y aura également va également mettre
en place sur votre tv
donc tous les discours seront retransmis
en direct pour les jeunes qui n'ont pas
pu être sur place pour les personnes qui
désirent regarder les discours sur
youtube enfin sur les ateliers faut
savoir que le campus sera donc articulé
entre séance plénière donc première
séance plénière qui démarre à 10h45
jusque 17h30 et d'une dernière séance
plénière le samedi autour de nicolas
sarkozy xavier bertrand est entre nous
aurons bien évidemment des séances
formation des ateliers
débats et d'échangés on aura des thèmes
majeurs comme la france face aux périls
dahesh la crise agricole en france
redonner le goût d'entreprendre encore
du marketing politique
les séances de média training le
dimanche des tables rondes sur le
gaspillage alimentaire ou encore sur la
fiscalité tient également mettre en
avant le fait qu'on a voulu faire venir
des personnalités civiles annoncé
important que ce soit si des gens du
milieu de l'entreprise sur du terrain
qui parle et on aura également par
exemple la présence de maxime louguet
qui était l'ancien responsable des
jeunes agriculteurs du nord ou encore la
présidente d'action contre la faim sur
la table ronde lors du gaspillage
alimentaire est vraiment grand que ce
soit 6 du débat la formation mais
également du débat qui est un véritable
échange autour des jeunes républicains
enfin pour le faire grandir un peu
ça sera un camping sur place on a voulu
faire quelque chose dans la bonne
entendre une bonne ambiance on est jeune
donc ça va être aussi avant tout un
événement convivial familial entre nous
et ça fait vraiment plaisir aux jeunes
républicains d'avoir enfin un campus
d'avoir enfin grampus nationale et je
pense que lors de ce campus on a prouvé
qu'avec peu de moyens et beaucoup
d'huile de coude on pouvait organiser
quelque chose de très correct
merci antoine tiens ça vient vraiment le
travail extraordinaire d'antoine et de
tous ses équipes parce que vraiment ils
ont pris sa lé bien pris les choses en
main avec l'expérience qu'ils avaient
des années précédentes mais là c'était
quand même un sacré défi c'était de
transformer campus régional en campus
nationale et je crois que ce défi il est
temps en passe d'être réussi parce qu'il
ya tout les tous les responsables
départementaux des jeunes qui sont
mobilisés vous avez rencontré à
plusieurs reprises la caravane d'été
d'ailleurs qui était un vrai succès un
cas d arrêt de nice et qui est arrivé au
touquet il ya quelques jours et cette
caravane d'été a été aussi l'occasion
pour les jeunes d'aller à la rencontre
d'autres jeunes
tout le long du littoral pendant cet été
pour faire passer le message et moi
aussi me concerne je pense que c'est le
cas aussi beaucoup de ceux qui sont ici
je pense qu'au coeur de la future
campagne des élections présidentielles
il y aura la question de la jeunesse
notre capacité à faire une vraie place
aux jeunes dans notre pays
et notre capacité à réformer pour faire
cette place que les jeunes n'ont pas
aujourd'hui il ya trop de jeunes
aujourd'hui qui sont au chômage ou qui
quittent le pays
c'est un véritable drame françois
hollande avait fait de la jeunesse sa
priorité
on voit que c'est un grave échec sur ce
plan il faut que nous fassions nous de
la jeunesse une vraie priorité mais
derrière il faut qu'on déroule de vrais
moyens de vraies réformes pour faire en
sorte que les jeunes se sentent bien en
france qu'ils ont envie de revenir en
france il envie de grandir en france et
d'évoluer en france et c'est ça le
message qu'on veut faire passer
aussi à l'occasion de ce campus